[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot this
is episode four point five here at
GameSpot I'm Mike McCarty and I'm Jake
and last week we spoke about persona 5
on reboot I specifically talked about
how it reacted my passion for JRPGs
which in the last decade or so kind of
waned with so many other kind of games
coming out and I lost you know lost
track of them lost interest in these
[ __ ] casual persona 5 got me back
into JRPGs or at least you know sparked
interest in them once again you know I
kind of passed up a bunch in recent
years and with a bunch of questions from
the episode I want to give Jake a chance
to talk about persona 5 and he's been
playing a lot and talk about kind of
what other JRPGs I'm excited for because
you know half the point of the video is
that it's kind of got me excited for
them again lots of great recommendations
- in the comments a lot of games because
I've kind of fallen off the JRPG train a
little bit maybe not as much as you have
but I definitely have and just looking
through those some games everything
don't play one game that was mentioned
was ninokuni though which is yes
Titan it we start off with this one on
twitter from spike Spiegel thank you so
much for tweeting at us great
installment of reboot this week curious
what JRPGs are up next for you after
persona 5 and why thank you um like you
were just mentioned I'm excited for
ninokuni - now which uh you know we've
seen a tiny bit of but you know like I
don't know too much about it I might
keep it that way I did play like eight
hours of ninokuni back in the day and I
know that's not nearly enough time to
get into it or most JRPGs but it piqued
my interest between like the you know
the animations of like you know yeah
this is a great story I think ninokuni
is probably how you felt when you played
persona 5 this time because that is what
got me back in the Japanese I'd say cuz
I really liked that game I think that
game is one of the best games of last
generation and it's kind of underrated
I'd say was a 2011 2012 doesn't know I
think it was 11 or 12 yeah I think it
was anyways January 2012 yeah so I'm
excited for that I'm excited we one of
the huge recommendations in the chat and
you know like I knew the persona 5 or
sorry persona was a spinoff from Shin
Megami Tensei and you know I've been I
know what Shin Megami Tensei is but
people keep recommending those to me I
might go back and just play for if I
have the time
I don't know talking about Suikoden -
and Chrono Trigger
kind of made me want to go back and play
sweet get into specifically playing
Dragon Age Inquisition what they were
trying to do with that obviously not at
JRPG but what they were trying to do
that I felt like Suikoden - actually did
much better in terms of building an army
and kind of going around and gathering
people to your cause but yeah the shin
megami tensei that they teased for the
switch on that direct when they were
showing off all the new games it looks
good I want to play that now because
someone said jean-luc here game so I was
he did a history of persona peace you
should go watch that if you haven't it's
like 25 minutes but it's really good oh
yeah it'll pull you through uh it'll be
interesting to see what I think in that
series after you know falling in love
with persona all of a sudden after five
do you have any desire to play persona 4
golden at all I do yeah um I I know that
was like the Vita system seller that is
where I got a via and that's what I want
to play the most I think after replaying
because I've played it I didn't finish
it I played like 70 hours that game
though but I really want to replay that
and I also want to replay Catherine I
don't know if you it's not the GRP Jean
SAT but it's made by the same people who
did persona 5 and it is a fantastic game
and then here's a comment on YouTube on
the video the YouTube crew said great
video my question is how do you think
persona 5 compares to Final Fantasy 15
that game got good reviews what seemed
like persona 5 as being better received
what do you think sets those two JRPGs
apart Jake you played more Final Fantasy
15 than I did right off the bat I mean
Final Fantasy 15 is more of a pure
open-world game in the sense that you
know you can go around doing all these I
felt like there were too many fetch
quests of like the ten hours I played I
didn't like the characters although
people said like you start to kind of
like some of them as time goes on I
didn't really dedicate enough time to it
but yes structurally I think persona 5
actually gave me more of that like
Bioware kind of linear building
relationships and recruiting a team and
you know it's funny because that's what
I was hoping for from Mass Effect
Andromeda and then persona 5 came out
and it gave me exactly what I was
looking for but in terms of how it
compares a final finished 15 you
probably better to answer that I mean
there's obviously a lot of there's a
bunch of obvious differences like once
real
time the other it what kind of real time
and then the other is turn-based uh one
takes place in a jet like what you're
saying a giant open world the other
takes place in a smaller world with
different activities within that world I
think probably the biggest difference is
just the direction I I feel like the
teaming atlas was way more focused on
what they wanted to accomplish with this
game well Final Fantasy 15 infamously
was known for being delayed like 10
years straight it seemed like it was
kind of going all over the place and the
final product was good but it didn't
live up to those those lofty
expectations that people had and yes
people had big expectations for persona
but we weren't expecting ridiculous
things we just wanted more persona we
wanted a better persona we wanted great
characters we want a good story and so
far it seems like that is delivering on
all that well Final Fantasy the story's
weak which is disappointing right for a
Final Fantasy game the world is cool but
there's not a whole lot to do in it I
think persona 5 will definitely go down
in history is one of the greatest RPG
JRPGs while I think Final Fantasy 15
will be remembered as a game that had
some developmental issues that came out
and wasn't as bad as people wanted to be
in it wasn't as bad as other people
thought it would be yeah it's crazy I
mean between the Last Guardian Final
Fantasy 15 and now persona 5 I know
persona 5 was in pre-production for
almost 10 years but you were just saying
that they wanted to finish Katherine
first but it's like the third of these
games that we've been waiting for for
like a decade Final Fantasy 15 last
Guardian and they both came out were
like holy [ __ ] these are real I have
them you know in my console right now
and then this comes out and you know
like like you said I feel like even more
so than the other two it kind of met
expectations you know you try to take
that out of the process when you're
actually like seeing what you think of
the games but it does kind of factor in
sometimes yeah now I'm just waiting for
Beyond Good and Evil - been a long way
to that one in half-life and half-life
there yep cool
the YouTube crew thank you so much for
your comment yes thank you yeah so then
we also did want to if you watch the
episode that you know we heavily stylize
it because persona 5 one of the things
that jumps out at people is its style
between it's uh you know it's graphic
novel kind of transitions in the menus -
it's really gorgeous anime cutscenes -
it's
awesome soundtrack - it's just bold
colors and crazy visuals uh we want to
kind of emphasize that so you watched
the episode you saw that our reboot
intro got interrupted like freeze-frame
and then all of a sudden like it's a
JRPG f5 version of me next - like the
ransom letters the Phantom thieves using
persona 5 jerk these are like really
talented motion graphics designer here
he's done some really cool stuff he did
this April Fool's video with Rob here
recently on like the faking like how to
pilot a guardian in Zelda but so we just
asked him if he could do some stuff with
it he made those transitions the screen
tearing away kind of making me like
Joker I guess from the game if you
played it so that was really fun and
just being able to use the soundtrack
from this game was awesome
so yeah overall it was a really fun
episode to shoot to write and to edit
and to work with a jerk on but we're
looking forward the next one which is
yeah so by the time the next one comes
out we will have seen the new Call of
Duty and it's not about Call of Duty we
are kind of talking about war in games
in general the problems games have had
with portraying it games that have done
it really well and what we can learn
from them because you know I love
shooters as my favorite genre so this
was a fun episode to write and to figure
out how to talk about but war can be a
touchy subject in games especially
because you know like we're the ones
playing it so some games have asked us
to do pretty [ __ ] up stuff in the
games and it's not justified then it can
be kind of messed up but we're looking
at games that have done that well you
know I don't want to just I'm not gonna
trash games I have worn them by default
yeah so we're getting into that and
we're going to be you know kind of tying
that into the new Call of Duty
announcement so we're looking forward to
getting that episode out yeah check back
next week yeah and in the meantime
on the next episode be sure to get more
comments in and tweeted me and we can
feature it on show like we did today
see you then see you
[Music]